Hey, welcome to 40 Days of Holiness. Grab your workbook.
You know what to do, right? We're going to take notes.
We're going to work through all this.
Today's theme, let's see, we are on, oh goodness, day
10 today. Holiness means purity from
corruption.
You ever seen the yin-yang symbol, right?
It's like this universal symbol in Eastern religions.
The basic idea is that there's dark and light balance in the
universe, and that in all light there is some dark, in all dark there is some
light.
Eastern thinkers basically came to this
conclusion studying the universe, and that it's kind of a,
honestly, natural conclusion to come to, right?
There's some good in all bad, there's some bad in all good.
Everything in the universe has its yin and its yang, some good, some bad, some
corruption, but in the corruption, there's some purity, and in the strength,
there's some weakness, in some dark, in some light.
Everything's mixed,
and the two are entangled. And that mixture includes
moral corruption.
So this can be in our actions like stealing, lying, and murder, and sometimes
that's in the life of a relatively good person in other areas. Here's the thing.
Yin and yang does not adequately explain the universe.
It doesn't. Here's why. Because God's not mixed.
He is utterly, unimaginably pure, completely incorruptible.
So when God calls us to be holy like he's holy, he's
requiring us to be untouched by that which
brings corruption. So God
talks about this kind of holiness in Leviticus, and he makes it a
violation of his holiness to be touched by dead body or have an
infection or touched by an unclean animal.
And if we want to know God, we have to be free from evil actions, free
from the guilt of sin. So Isaiah 59:2 says,
"But your iniquities have separated you from God.
Your sins have hidden his face from you so that he will not hear."
But the corruption of sin goes deeper than just the actions that verse is talking
about. It goes down into motivations, too.
So this is why Jesus' teachings were so revolutionary.
He taught in such a way that he exposed the heart of
people. When he taught, he showed it was possible to do even
right things from wrong motives.
There's lie mixed with honesty, or
ambition, which is good, right, mixed with greed.
There is selflessness that's mixed with selfish motive.
Jesus even taught that there could be
giving mixed with pride
or arrogance mixed with prayer.
In other words,
even good actions can be mixed with morally
corrupting motivations and influence.
Now, the New Testament has many pictures of this, like Ezekiel
14:4 says this: "Therefore, speak to them and tell them
this is what the Sovereign Lord says.
When any of the Israelites set up idols in their
hearts, the Lord will answer them in keeping with
their great idolatry." In other words, he's saying it's not just an idol in the
corner of your house. The problem is that the idol got out of the corner of your
house and got into your heart.
Isaiah 6 talks about it as an issue of lips.
Isaiah says, "I'm a man of unclean lips." And this becomes really
important when you remember that in the New Testament, Jesus talks about
it as the heart and the mouth together.
Out of the overflow of the heart, the mouth speaks.
So Isaiah's problem showed up in his mouth, but it came from his
heart, even though he was right with God and was literally God's
prophet.
Now David talks about it this way in Psalm 51:5.
"Surely I was sinful at birth, sinful from the
time my mother conceived me."
And then he goes on to ask God to cleanse him with
hyssop. Now, in Leviticus, in the Old Testament, hyssop was used
in the purification ceremony for when you had come into contact with a
dead body or leprosy, something that defiled you.
So before you could come back into the holy place, into the presence of
God, the temple or tabernacle, you had to be sprinkled with
hyssop, symbolically cleansing you from the
potential corruption of being unclean.
So put this together. David's saying this corruption that's inside
is like being present from the time I was born and before, is
like being continually in contact with a dead body.
I need to be sprinkled so I can come back into the presence of God.
It keeps me continually stuck in the outer levels of holiness.
I can't come to the middle, to the center where God is.
David's like, "This internal corruption's keeping me from
journeying deep into God's essential nature.
It keeps me from really getting into him and knowing him."
It's the same for me and you.
Now, tomorrow, we're going to look more at this nature of what it's like.
I will give you a brief word of warning here.
We're going into a few hard days, okay? Buckle up.
We're going to look in the mirror. We're going to talk about some uncomfortable
realities. We're going to clean out the wound so it
can heal.
All right? You know you got to do that, right?
Sometimes you got to clean out the wound before it can heal.
But listen,
God can heal the wound of the heart.
Don't get discouraged by the clean-out process.
Don't get discouraged by the fact that we've got to dive in deep and figure out
what the problem is all the way down to the core.
It's not enough to just play around the edges and say, "I'm going to clean up some
of these public things in my life and do holier stuff."
God says, "I want to dive down deep and transform not just the actions on the
outside, but the motivations of the heart." So
let's do that, all right? Let's go deep with the Lord, and
be willing to stick with me for the next few days.
I promise it's going to get more encouraging.
The next few days, you're going to look inside and say,
"I see what's here, and I see where there's corruption.
I see where there's negative things, and I want God to clean it out."
All right? So stick with me. Do the workbook.
Let's stay with it for the next few days, and God's going to heal some things, some
really deep stuff in your heart and in our hearts. All right? God bless you.
See you tomorrow.